ring ring ring ring ah sis PJ what's
that you think my try not to life
challenge videos aren't funny enough if
you still there oh can you challenge me
you're going to send me the clips this
time because you want funny one okay
actually you know what I appreciate your
helping out because I've been really
struggling with getting decent content
out you're sending me over some clips
okay
okay PJ thank you so much domo arigato
sayonara set PJ sama all right let's see
what PJ has to offer spend that sheets
at PJ PJ I've never laughed in a china
to live challenge in my entire life
why don't you join this challenge Minh
and try to keep up the goal is not to
laugh
thanks for the treats crap okay that'll
be 3203
one drink your grandson ordered a bunch
of cakes and he said it was all on you
[Music]
I give up I give up that's some fine
editing right there that I cannot I
cannot yeah damnit the first [ __ ]
video really PJ yep you know no that
doesn't count
what the [ __ ] is it what goes on in this
town is none of your business as long as
I'm living here it is
[Applause]
oh that's easily fixed
now it's hard that's correct
that's some fine acting right there no
editing just acting
oh that's easily fixed hi this is going
to be tough PJ come on me cut me some
slack here pretend to fight gone wrong
oh geez wait wait wait did you say a
spaghett did he say Oh spaghetti when
he's hit got hit Oh oh my god he thinks
oh forget it
oh okay nope
did not laughs I like that myself
doesn't [ __ ] count try again PJ fat
kid
part three what do you mean part three
what does that mean wait how do you find
these [ __ ] random [ __ ] videos
Jesus
[Music]
Bravo miss ya society engine magnifique
that's the finest f-sharp I have ever
heard in my goddamn life
it sounded just like my mother when she
was singing me singing to me as a child
my mother was a pterodactyl
[Applause]
[Music]
then busting Christ
[Applause]
[Music]
what the hell is happening that was it
that was it
What is the title grandma found the keys
but Gregg what are you doing today
Myron all right you know no I don't want
to know I don't want to know I want to
sleep tonight thank you very much
so mama is so fat that she had to get
baptized and she ruled no no that no I
did not laugh at that shitty [ __ ]
video [ __ ] you know come on your hands
it keeps the voice isn't your thing out
no it keeps me in everything I keep some
in out in out in any bad spaghetti ah
how do you find these [ __ ] channels
PJ
it scares me I'm scared I'm scared of
you now congratulations that's what you
what the [ __ ] hey hey what's going on
mr. Rimmer honey bars just missed it
will we miss man yeah you just missed
her come on mr. Rimmer man what we met
yeah we miss man come on mr. Rimmer man
a donkey fell into a bowl of sugar now
that's a sweet 1/2
[Music]
now that's a sweet is I love that one
I'm subscribe to that China it's so good
hey no talking house Internet is a weird
place and PJ you're not [ __ ] helping
I want that robot it's [ __ ] awesome
these are the kind of videos where it's
like when people that's got the will
robots take over humanity just show them
this video and be like I think we're
fighting for a couple more years at
least furniture advert good news for
people and of credit problems wooden
furniture is here for you now seriously
if you can't get get it in my store you
can't get credit anywhere
my name is Mac and you can count on it I
think I will not go to that store mainly
based on the guy with a [ __ ] giant
scissor and the nightmares
oh sweet reporter farts it's amazing
they're wrapping up the show she's doing
the outro and here we go they're at a
salute for the favicon and they see
arrows for Monday yeah head up that's
Lisa
she listed she was a literally sat on
that part for for a very long time and
the video she was doing so well she's
doing so incredibly while holding in
that far and as soon as she ended it it
just it just slipped out we've all done
that but to do it on television and to
be so [ __ ] loud
but the microphone that's precision here
picks it up from your [ __ ] [ __ ]
and it sounds louder than you speak
that's something beautiful how about
that another Swedish one what the [ __ ]
I love silicon care silicon Kearney
[Music]
given that the thing is like they say
shellac incarnate in a funny way you
would say like that it's funny how he
says it I can't explain why it's funny I
don't know how this would be funny for
other people I thought yeah at a
Schedule II couldn't care na I love
shellac incarnate who actually had I
think it's in the Swedish blood
Oh God Oh God oh I see he's nicer right
I was
Oh congratulations you subscribed to the
PewDiePie channel have fun editing that